so we have a function f of x that's
written as the product of a bunch of
first degree expressions now if we we
obviously could also view this as a
polynomial especially if we expand this
all out it'll have our more traditional
form but what's nice about this form and
this is where we try to get when we're
trying to find the zeros or the roots of
a polynomial is that it's very easy to
pick out the zeros
the zeros here these are the x values
that make our function equal to zero
well that's going to be x is equal to
two
x is equal to negative 4. that would
make this expression 0. x is equal to
negative 5. remember if you make any one
of these equal to 0 then the entire
function is going to be equal to 0
because 0 times anything is 0.
x equals 1.
and x is equal to 9.
now as we've talked about in multiple
videos these are also going to be the if
these x values when you input into the
function give you f of 2 equals 0 or f
of negative 4 is equal to 0 then that
means that they're also going to define
our x-intercepts what am i talking about
so let me draw
let me draw a big axis here see we go as
low as x equals negative 5 as high as x
equals 9. so
let me draw something like this
so it's my y-axis this is my x-axis
x is 1 2
3
4 5 6
5. all right
now let's just plot these so when x is
equal to 2
f of 2 we already know is 0. if you
input 2 here then this expression is
going to be zero zero times a bunch of
stuff is going to be zero
so f of two is equal to zero so the
point two comma zero
is going to be on the graph of y equals
f of x
so one two comma zero so that's that
point right over there so notice x
equals 0 x equals 2 is a 0 and makes our
function it equal to 0 if you input it
into it and it's also the point 2 comma
0. it's going to be the x coordinate
of it's going to be the x coordinate of
this point right over here it's going to
define our x into or one of our x
intercepts let's do it with the other
ones x is equal to negative 4. i can do
that with a better color x is equal to
negative 4 negative one negative two
negative three negative four
right over there x is equal to negative
five
x is equal to
negative five
x is equal to one
and do that in
i will do that in pink
x is equal to 1
and x is equal to 9
and x is equal to 9 that was that right
over there right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
now i'm not going to be able to exactly
draw the graph of this function but
what's neat is i can realize well look
if these are the points where i'm going
to intercept the x-axis and these are
the only points where i'm going to
intercept the x-axis the zeros the real
zeros define the
all of the points at which i'm going to
intercept the x-axis because think about
if there was a point that intercepted
the x-axis that wasn't a zero well it
wouldn't be a zero because the function
would take on the value zero there
so between those points if the function
will will stay positive or will stay
negative and we can we can test that a
little bit
let's think about let's think about what
the function is doing between x equals
negative 4 and x equals 1. so over
this interval right over here
well let's let's just pick a value there
and then think about whether the
function is going to be positive or
negative at that value and an easy value
to think about is maybe
zero
and i just want to think about the sign
is the function going to be positive or
negative when x is equal to 0.
so f of 0
f of 0. i'm just going to think about it
sine
so the f of 0 is going to be 0 minus 2
well that's going to be negative
0 plus 4 that's going to be positive
0 plus 5 that's going to be positive
0 minus 1 is going to be negative
0 minus 9 is going to be negative
so we can see since at at x equals zero
we're going to get a let's see negative
this is going to be a negative
times a negative which would be a
positive and then we multiply by a
negative again so this is going to be
equal to
this is going to get us to a negative so
the function is going to take on a
negative value here and we know it's
going to take on a negative value over
this entire interval
over this entire interval because if for
some reason it took on a positive value
over that entire over that interval it's
a continuous function it would have to
cross the x-axis and that would define
another zero but we know there aren't
any zeros between these two points so
the function i don't know what it looks
like but it's going to stay positive
between those two values
now as you go to a next interval it's
probably going to change signs and we
can verify that if you look at f if you
look at say f of negative
4.5 so we'll do the same drill
f of negative 4.5
well that's going to be
that's going to be a
see negative
times a negative
times a positive negative 4.5 plus 5 is
a positive
times the negative
times a negative
well we have an even number of negatives
being multiplied together here so this
is going to give us a positive so this
is going to give us a positive value
so we're going to have a positive value
between these two points and then we're
likely to flip back to negative after
that so then the graph is likely to flip
back
flip back to
negative right over there you can test
that try a try a really negative value
so f of
negative 10
well that's going to be a
negative
times a negative times a
negative let's see times a negative
times a
negative
times a negative so you have five
negatives being multiplied together
you're going to have a negative
hopefully you see where all this is
going so this is we're likely to switch
signs here you can test 1.5 and see if
you get a positive value then we're
likely to switch back here once again
the graph isn't going to look exactly
like this the it might it might dip
it might be fairly shallow here and then
it might dip down a lot right here i'm
just making up the parts on the ups and
downs and then it probably does another
sign change right over there and we can
verify that if f of positive 10
well that's going to be a positive
times a positive
times a positive times a positive times
a positive
times positive times a positive so we're
positive after that and i don't know
exactly what it looks like but the key
the key realization here is that the
zeros are the only place that we're
going to intercept the x-axis and
between those zeros if you're a positive
if you're positive on that interval
you're going to be positive on any point
if you're positive at one point in that
interval you're going to be positive at
any point in that interval and if you're
negative at any point in that interval
then you're going to be negative
throughout the interval and of course at
the ends of the interval you're going to
be at 0. so if someone were to say what
is the sine of f if someone would say
sine
of f
on the interval
on
say negative 4 is less than x is less
than 1.
well that's this interval it goes from
negative 4
to 1. so that's the interval we actually
started off with
that's that interval right over there
you'd say oh well look f is always
negative on this interval if you don't
include the endpoints and we're not
including the endpoints here we don't
have a less than or equal either point
here so here it's always negative if
someone gave you a different interval if
they gave you an interval that includes
where 0 is part of the interval so
someone said if someone said the
interval from
i don't know the interval from
1
to 9.
well that's going to include a 0 in it
so it's going to be positive it's going
to be sometimes positive and sometimes
negative on this interval so the key is
between the two between two roots not
including the two roots if you have an
interval between two roots then you're
always going to be positive or you're
always going to be negative over that
interval whatever the sign is at any
point of interval is going to sign
throughout that interval not including
the endpoints